a breakthrough in the negotiations
between Greece and its eurozone partners
the list of reforms presented by the
Greek government on Monday has been
accepted by its creditors on Tuesday
Eurogroup present your own days'll bloom
discussed Greece's reform plan with
Economic Affairs Committee it's not
going to be easy this is just a first
step this list is not a new MOU or a new
agreement this list is just an
indication of the kind of reforms that
they would like to push like to replace
and also the ones that they would like
to continue our Parliament rolled out
the red carpet for Belgium as King
Philip and his wife Queen Mathilde on
Wednesday they were received by
President Schultz followed by a meeting
with political group leaders it was a
couple's first visit to parliament since
King Philip's coronation in July 2013
this year 47 out of 90 candidates
received Parliament's European citizens
prize every year the prize is awarded to
citizens associations and organizations
committed to European values such as
helping the most vulnerable fighting
against racism and acting freedom of
speech without the pies [ __ ] lemon pies
pick up this burg our prizes hex leash
be common heist mmmm
the mini plenary in Brussels focused not
only on Greece's reform efforts the
Ukraine crisis and the fight against
terrorism but also on a common energy
policy Commissioner Merrill chef Jovic
outlined his priorities to any penis it
should increase the competition on the
internal energy market because it should
drive the prices down the Europe of the
21st century they wouldn't we shouldn't
have the such a high percentage of
citizens who cannot afford to pay day
energy bills not all MEP s those share
his vision of a European energy union